-Hey, guys. It's Jimmy.
I'm here in beautiful
Puerto Rico at Toro Verde,
and I'm about
to ride The Monster.
It's one of the longest
zip lines in the world.
Now, Tariq, you've done
zip lines before.
Where have you zip lined before?
-Fiji, Hawaii, New Jersey.
-Jersey?
-Yeah.
-Quest, we asked you, would you
like to ride the zip line?
And you responded with --
-Ah, heh, no.
-Guys, I am actually
scared of heights.
I don't know how
I'm going to do this.
I'm just gonna close my eyes
and go for it.
Are you ready to do this, Tariq?
-I guess, yeah. Let's do it.
-Here we go.
[ Breathes sharply ]
♪♪
That's the zip line there.
You're our guides?
-Yeah, we're the guides.
-Hey. Jimmy.
-Jimmy? Nice to meet you.
-Nice to meet you, too. Jimmy.
-First we need to do
The Monster, buddy.
We're gonna do the second
longest in the world.
First one in the Americas.
-Okay.
-We're talking about 2.3
kilometers to go down.
400 meters up.
Have fun with it.
-We're gonna have fun with it.
-Have fun with it.
-[ Laughs ]
-Jeez.
-Let's go. Come on, Tar--
-Are you sure about this, guys?
-Wait, can I just --
I conquered The Monst--
Can I just take a photo here
now and then...
-Nah, nah, nah, you cheatin'.
-...act like I did it?
-That's cheating.
That's cheating.
-That should be at the bottom.
-That's cheating. Come on.
-I just want to make sure
you're gonna do it.
-Who's been doing -- who's been
working here the longest?
-You want that answer?
-[ Laughs ]
-Extra tight.
-Yeah, I gotta.
I mean, dude, I got things
I gotta worry about in there.
My phone and my wallet.
What were you thinking I was
talking about?
A backpack?
-Yeah.
-Why would I be wearing
a backpack?
-There's a parachute there.
Something happens,
we need to make sure --
-No, dude, absolutely not!
What is going on?
-Come on. Come on.
-...the one you're gonna
use for --
-Your hair, man,
is going to get messed up.
-Fun.
This feels like fun.
This is what people do
to have fun, I guess.
-You good?
-It's the silliest --
Yeah, no it feels good.
-Feels good?
-My double chin is --
[ Deeper voice ]
It's altering my voice, but...
Yeah,
I guess it's a little tight,
but I guess I'll just talk
like this for the rest of --
I sound like Shaggy.
♪ It wasn't me ♪
♪ And then did it
on my counter ♪
♪ It wasn't me ♪
-Say "Harry Potter."
-Harry -- Harry Potter.
-Old San Juan is down there.
That's the whole North Coast,
completely.
-Wow, it is --
-Really high up.
-Just beautiful.
-Beautiful, man.
-Yeah, I'm good here.
I mean, I can take this
and go home and be psyched.
♪♪
-I'll try it later for you.
-Nah.
-Stand up right here.
-Why you shaking, buddy?
-[ Chuckles ]
-Can you hear that shaking?
-If this bridge was so safe,
why would they need that?
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh!
Stop shaking the bridge!
Tariq, it's not funny, dude.
-This could potentially mean
"The Tonight Show
With Questlove."
[ Wind whooshing ]
♪♪
-[ Sighs ]
Whew...
Oh...
-Are you ready to fly?
-Ohh!
-And in this series finale
of "The Tonight Show Starring
Jimmy Fallon" --
-[ Exhales ]
-Hey, Jimmy...
-Yeah?
-You have done zip line
before, right?
-Never.
-Oh, my God.
-The harness will feel weird
on your knees.
-Okay.
-That's normal.
Once you lay down,
you're almost ready to go.
-Ohh!
♪♪
-Oh, man!
-Walk up front.
-Dude, I do not like this
at all.
-You're gonna stand right --
-Oh, dude!
-You're going to stand
right here, sir.
-Now, the thing
is gonna get real.
I need you to start laying down
on your stomach
like doing pushups.
-Okay, let go.
-[ Grunts ]
-Oh, my God!
Watch it!
[ Shudders ]
-Sir, comfortable?
-Oh! Oh!
-Am I comfortable?
I wouldn't say comfortable.
-Just a little bit.
-I'm going to throw up.
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
-All set?
-Have fun. Tariq, have fun.
-Have fun, guys.
-Thank you so much
for having me. Thank you.
-You're welcome.
-He's counting down.
-In 5, 4, 3,
2, 1, go!
-Hey, Jimmy. Hey, Tariq!
-Viva Puerto Rico!
-[ Laughing ]
-Puerto Rico!
-Wow!
-Yo!
-[ Shouts indistinctly ]
-Oh!
-[ Shouts ]
-[ Shouting ]
-Wow!
-[ Shouts ]
-Ohh!
-Oh, my God!
Ohh!
Oh, my God!
-[ Laughs ]
-Whoo!
-My lips are sticking
to my teeth.
-Oh! Oh!
-Beautiful!
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-Coming in fast, dude.
-I know.
-Ohh! Oh, yeah!
-Ohh!
-Ha ha!
-Yo, that [bleep]
was amazing!
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah!
-Oh -- oh, my God.
-Dude, that [bleep] was dope.
-Get me -- Oh.
Oh, my God.
Get me home.
Get me the hell home.
-Oh, man!
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
-Oh, man.
-That was insane.
-It was amazing.
-All right, get me to a bar
or somewhere.
I need some Pitorro.
-Pitorro.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-We did it.
We conquered The Monster.
And now it's time for a cheers.
Cheers.
-Salud.
-Man, get out of here.
You don't get --
-Get out of here!
-Dude, you're drinking alone.
Cheers, buddy.
♪♪